[Music]
you'll probably read this three people
have won the Mega Millions lottery yeah
you know what that means three more
votes for Mitt Romney and pull the lever
uh speaking of Mitt Romney does the
latest yes yesterday in Wisconsin
Mitt Romney staff played an April Fool's
Day prank by taking Romney to a fake
campaign event
yeah and Newt Gingrich's campaign staff
played an April Fool's prank on Newt by
telling him things are looking great you
should stay in the race today have you
heard this today Newt Gingrich said that
Mitt Romney has no principles now in
other words he has given Romney his
official endorsement I can't believe
this people are already I have had it
with this election it still isn't taking
place for a long time people are already
talking about the 2016 election yeah
Bill Clinton said this is a quote he
said he would be happy if Hillary ran
for president in 2016
yeah he also said he'd be happy if she
left the house for half-hour this
Saturday from 335
[Applause]
he could have been ordering a pizza it's
for you to interpret a court in eat well
that was look at that gesture I didn't
do that a lot in the monarch that's very
theatrical that's like that other in the
news a court in Egypt is cracking down
on all Egyptian pornographic websites
yeah the the worst offender is Egypt's
topless website
those aren't pyramids dot-com that was
stupid I'm talking to you people that
have plotted that you might have heard
about this this is a controversial
iTunes has announced that a
controversial app has been pulled after
people said it was designed for stalkers
yeah the developers say they will
resubmit their app under its original
name Facebook
how high can I get this button right now
[Applause]
why it's so weird yeah it's kinda it's
kind of Nixon II I know
[Applause]
when 3d television comes out I'm gonna
be the host new scientific study just
revealed something interesting according
to a new scientific study the oceans
started warming 135 years ago that
amazing yeah it was that long ago that
someone first looked at the ocean and
said hey I can pee in that Bank Oprah we
were talking about that backstage we
never said we're gonna have to hold for
applause I can pee on that thing hold
for applause
Oprah Winfrey's longtime boyfriend
Stedman Graham has written a book about
being proud of who you are now not
helping is that the cover of the book
says written by Oprah's boyfriend
[Applause]
[Music]
the opto mom is back in the news yeah
I'm with you on this one yeah in a new
interview the Octomom said that she's
received a flood of angry phone calls
and death threats yeah yeah and that's
just from her uterus
[Applause]
so here just give me a break please